[Music]
was a powerful presentation it was
greatest to meet you out there to talk a
little bit about what I meant both you
guys being out there especially
considering to release the documentary
and to be able to really like have the
music and she stopped in yet respect the
biggie was on such a a really kind of
commercial level you know and it was it
was something I was beautiful you know
saying and have a son first time we've
been on stage together first time he's
made an appearance and also big it's
Biggie's 45th birthday so all of that
and then you know it's just a beautiful
night and dropping the trailer you know
yeah man's great can't stop won't stop
you know it's gonna be available June
25th look out for could I ask you would
you ever consider being a judge on Idol
on the new Idol would you ever do
something like that I mean only if they
wanted to real I don't think like a lot
of TV can handle the real so a lot of
the shows is kind of like kind of fluffy
but if I don't handle the real and they
can handle my price tag you know are
coming for three days out the week